where am i we're down here in georgia
baby down here in georgia
with some creativity you can shoot
almost anything here in atlanta we have
all our stages here they've taken such
good care of us we are so lucky to be
here
there's a great crew here there are
facilities here there's equipment here
the vendors are fantastic
the scale of what they have is not to be
underestimated and to see it grow and
evolve each year
it's great badass and it's amazing to
have a single home where we can have
three or four productions going on at a
time the quality of the set build the
paint work the effect just puts you
right back on your game full credit to
the set designers and all the crew that
have just made it look incredible i
can't believe i'm in the sanctum
sanctorum
there's not a lot of states where you
can do that where they have the
facilities and they have the equipment
to manage that level of production you
won't know that it's not in new york
when you see it
[Applause]
[Music]
you